はいみなさんお晩でございます
秋田の言葉でこんばんはですね
影響で私の格好どうでしょうか
ありがとうございます
これは割烹着と言って日本の伝統的なお母さんのスタイルです
とっても機能的毎日着てます
越冬
今朝皆さん何を食べましたか
昨日の夜のことは
覚えていますか
お叱りに
これがあなたの人生最後の食事ですと言われたら
何が食べたいですか
ちょっと思いつきますか
私はあ
きたての白いご飯となめこのお味噌汁
とてもシンプルだけれど
ゆっくり味わうととっても贅沢なもの
毎日でも飽きないで食べれるもの
皆さんはどうでしょう
食べるといふ事どのぐらい意識していますか
ん
このふわふわもこもこしたものは何でしょう
これは工事です
ポチッ
醤油味噌んミリオすっ
日本の調味料を作る時になくてはならないものです
講師がそれ単体よりも他の何かと合わせた時にその力を発揮します
沢山の微生物が分泌する酵素が働くことで
味噌や醤油のように全く形の異なるものを作ることができます
このことを発行と言います
麹を使った発酵は日本が世界に誇る技術です
昔から食べつながれてきたものにはたくさん工事が使われています
私は秋田県横手市にある糀屋に生まれました
横手市ば雪国秋田の中でも特に役の多いところ
雪がたくさん降るをかけでミネラルたっぷりのおいしいお水を飲むことができます
美味しいお水を蓄えて超えた土地に
愛をこめが実ります
私たちの暮らし方は
米作りを中心に構成されています
農家さんの暮らしには工事が欠かせない
地域の食文化に大きく関わる工事あに生まれて
食べることが身近にあったはずなのに私は食べるということには全く興味がありません
でした
小さい頃の私はとてもおてんばな女の子でした
小中高校と競技スキーに明け暮れ
体も今よりずっと大きくて
健康を絵にかいたような女の子でした
進学就職結婚と
親元を離れて県外へ移してみます
仕事が楽しくて
楽しくて
楽しすぎて夢中になっています
早く寝なさいとか
残さず食べなさいとかクチュール作用となが近くにいない暮らしが本当に楽しくて
私は背中に羽が生えたように自由に元気
とび-1
仕事に費やしてきました
子育てをしながらの仕事はとても大変でしたか
私は自分が自由にできる時間を
すべて
仕事に使いました
私は自分の体のことなど全く
会えていませんでした
気がつくと
体調の優れない日が続きました
そしてある日
私だ
とっても厄介な病気にかかっているということがわかったのです
お薬でコントロールしましたが
私の体はなかなか言うことを聞いてくれませんでした
少しの身の回りのことを除いてほとんど
布団の中で過ごすようになりました
黒と体がバラバラのようで
本当につらかった
なかなか元気にならない私は
秋田に帰りたいって言っ
思うようになりました
建てたばかりの家を売り
息子を転校させて
夫も私のために仕事を辞めました
家族全員で秋田へ帰ってきたのです
家族を巻き添えにして秋田へ帰ってきても私はやっぱり布団の中にいました
そんな私に母が毎日ご飯を作ってくれました
小さい頃に食べていた
ご飯お味噌汁季節の野菜のいわゆる和食の
普通の子派
ある日のこと
食欲がなくても何か一つは食べなさい
母に沿う流されて口にした味噌汁か
区バー
体にしみ込む不思議な感覚を味わえます
このあたりが
暖かくなっ
そうだ
そうだった
私の体は食べたものでできている
何かで頭をガツンと叩かれたような強い衝撃を受けた私に
続けてあぁが言いました
n 前にある景色を丸ごと食べているんだよ
外を見てもらおう
そこらにそこにあったものは
天に向かってまっすぐ青々と伸びる犬でした
そうだ
私の体は美味しいお米と
ちいちゃんの畑の野菜と
あの子を向く山から流れてくるいき時の水でできたんだ
秋冬
美しい亀裂
美味しいお水
田んぼのお米
お米で作る調味料
全部が繋がっていて私の体になっている
私はこの景色の一部なんだって
そこからで私は食べることに夢中になります
食べると力が湧いてきて
体がよく動くということが分かりました
どんなにつらい朝でも味噌汁一杯飲むことで元気が湧いてくるっていう
お土産同法という言葉があります
その土地で採れたものをその土地に伝わる食べ方で料理するのか
もっとも自然で体にいいという考え方
収納食材を自分たちの食べ方で食べる
とても日本らしい考え方のようにも思いますか
これは和食に限ったことではないかもしれません
生まれ育った環境で口にしたもの
その人にとって無条件で懐かしいって
感じるもの
現代の私たちは
日本にいながら世界中のおいしい食べ物や食べ方を体験することができます
自分たちの食べ物や食べ方を意識しなくても
食べるものはあふれています
その判明
食べるといふ事をないがしろにすることもできるようになりました
歩きながら飲むジェルのようなものや
スマホいじりながらつなぐスナック
これはもう食事ですがなくて
服を満たすためだけど
餌
頭ではわかってるんですけどね
ゆっくりお料理したりじっくり味わって食べたら美味しいに決まってます
そんなことはわかってい
でも
現代の私たちは忙しい
いつも急いでいます
早くすることが良いこととされているようにも思います
私も息子に入ってしまいます
早く起きなさい
早く食べなさい早くせください
忙しいという字が心を亡くすと書きます
確かに忙しい私たちは
体の中に心がない
離れてしまっているように感じる瞬間があります
でも
私たちの身体板
食べたものでできています
心だって体の一部です
ところで私が今
食べることを仕事にしています
と3度方でお客様をおもてなしするレストランです
ある時の出来事があって
食べることに夢中になって
経済の私があります
お店の台所で一緒に働いているのは何年も家族の健康のためにお料理して来たお母さん
たち
講師の使い方や食べ方の知識がてんこ盛りです
お母さんたちが作る料理は何を食べさせた以下のメッセージがはっきりと伝わってくる
ものです
旬の食材にはエネルギーがあります
味付けはそいでそいで
なるべくシンプルに
魔法のように工事を使いこなして出来上がったお料理は
全部
素材の味がします
じゃ外部や
タマネギの甘さだったり
青野菜の清々しい香りが全面にくるもので
調味料で食材を汚さないとっても美しいものです
お母さんたちと台所に立って御料理をならうちにわかってきたことがあります
これは
現在の忙しい私たちにとってとても良いことです
まず
伝統的な建物はその土地のすべてを移しているということ
例えば私が暮らす横手のお味噌は講師を大豆の3倍も使えます
お米がたくさん取れるとか工事をたくさん入れると甘くておいしくなる
という理由のほかに
講師をたくさん使うと発酵がよくすすぐ
ということもあります
横手の気温を1年で平均すると大大大大
10度前後だそうです
寒い地方ならではのハイ方なんですね
女丁味噌暖かい地方へ持っていったら
チェックす前
腐ってしまうかもしれません
私たちの素性はそのことを体験から知っていて
暮らしに合った人づくりをしてきたのです
伝統的な食べ物には
消えてなくならない皮膚があります
を一つ
伝統的な食べ方には
現在私たちに活かすことができるヒントがたくさんあるということ
さっき私は麹を使ったお料理は蔬菜味と言いました
いつからか私たちは
調味料味のものを好んで食べるようになりました
スーパーの調味料コーナーに並ぶ味付けのもと
の多さに驚きますよね
あれは現在忙しい私たちのために開発されたものでしょ
袋を開けて混ぜれば
に味がつく
佐藤さんの家でも山田さんの家でも同じ味
中もへったくれもあったもんじゃありません
新鮮な食材が手に入ったときば
公益って素材味
挑戦してみませんか
和食に限らずいつもの蒸したり焼いたりするお料理に工事を一緒に使うのです
そうすることで
食材の美味しさがキュッと引き出されて
杉田味付けが必要なくなります
この子そのものには味はありませんが
素材を軟らかくしたり
味の区域を作ったりしてくれるのです
調味料はごくごく基本的なものだけ
どうぞ素材味
体験してみてください
あ実教シンプルにすると
台所の調味料だなもう
それからお料理に使う時間もシンプルになりますよ
そして
もう一つ
とても大事なこと
素材味のものをじっくりゆっくり味わって食べているとホッとするということ
心が体に帰ってくるように思います
現代の私たちは忙しい
どこかへ行ってしまった心
ひょ日戻してみてください
毎日じゃなくてもいい
でも
食べるということを
意識してみてください
が一つしかない自分の体ま
自分が選んで食べたものでできています
3200グラムで生まれた私は40年ちょっとで約15倍の重さになりました
全部
全部私が選んで食べたものでできています
何で出来ていますか
食べることを通して自分を見つめ直す
心を体に返す
食べること
大切にする
あなたが選んで食べたもので
だ一つしかないあなたの体をつくってください
ありがとうございました4
[音楽]
[拍手]